[Music]
what up friends Drex here from
drexfactor POI sharing with you the love
of poi spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain and a lot of recent
videos I have been kind of investigating
different aspects of timing and
Direction and there's a specific idea
related to timing and direction that I
wanted to explore and kind of embellish
upon more specifically which is of
course the idea of split time versus
together time why do we Loop together
these timings despite the fact that you
know they look quite different from each
other much before we get into all that I
do just want to give a quick shout out
to the Friends of the channel big thanks
to dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing businesses and
what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel Johnny Howard Lane machinsky and
Becca beckonen thank you all so very
much for your support for my work and my
mission hey so as you're learning timing
and direction it's pretty hard to miss
the timing aspect of that we talk about
it in a lot of different respects but I
usually talk about it in terms of like
phasing whereas you know when we're
moving the POI or our hands and
shoulders in together same what we're
doing is we're kind of moving two
different objects around the same track
at the same time that is they're phased
together and when we move in Split time
they are faced apart from each other
now
I think that makes a lot of sense when
we talk about movements in where you
know the POI are moving in the same
direction like you know as I'm moving in
together same here I think it's pretty
intuitive to see that to pull your face
together and when I split them apart
they're moving in Split time right it's
almost like there's you know kind of a
race course and it's either the POI as
they're going through the race courts
are neck and neck with each other or
they're opposite ends the track if that
makes sense right
now it's a little bit less intuitive why
we call
this version of opposites together time
and this one split Pine it seems it
seems kind of arbitrary right because
you know no matter which direction I
spin this figure in the POI will always
be moving together and no matter how I
rotate this figure the POI will always
be at opposite ends of it right whereas
when the POI are moving in opposites
there's always going to be a point at
which they're coming together and a
point at which they're going apart
regardless of whether they're moving in
what we're calling together time or
split time the difference being of
course that in together time they're
meeting at the top and bottom and
they're separated to either side and in
Split time they're coming together at
either side and split top and bottom
so why do we call one of these together
time and the other one split time
because it seems like those are a little
bit more arbitrary than they would be
with the POI moving together right
um now there's absolutely no reason why
you need an answer to this question
aside from just curiosity's sake after
all knowing what makes this split time
doesn't necessarily make it any easier
and it you know doesn't really open up
anything in terms of theory it's just
it's kind of a cool bit of I don't know
if you want to call it trivia or minutia
or what but you know I'm also a very
curious person and so when I see
something I don't understand my brain
inevitably is like I want an explanation
for this so
the good news is I do have an
explanation for this
um I have the first explanation that I
encountered for this which I don't think
is that satisfying and I have another
explanation for this that I think is
very satisfying so I will offer them
both up to you and if you are not an
absolute nerd like I am that's okay uh
maybe you can Regal your friends with
this at a later date or I don't know you
know it maybe this is the lesson that
you skip I won't uh I won't take it uh I
won't take it too personally if you do
all right so to start with
um we have to talk about the
kinesthetics of each of these things so
as I'm doing together time
same direction
I am I I the the energy that I'm putting
into the POI to get them to go up and
over I am putting that into both POI
exactly the same time my hands for all
intents and purposes are performing the
same action at the same time up down up
down up down up down right likewise when
I'm moving in
together opposites I'm
I'm putting energy into them to go up
above my hands at the same time and
letting them drop at the same time up
down up down up down right so they both
go up they both go down
um in terms of just like what my hands
are doing it's the same kind of
phenomenon of like pushing the pulley up
pulling them down pushing the POI up
pulling them down regardless of whether
they're going
in the same direction
or in opposite directions right
um
and of course when we go over to our
split timings here
um I have to think in a different way I
have to think one hand is doing up as
the other hand is doing down and vice
versa up down up down sometimes I think
about this almost as though I'm doing a
roll on a snare drum right like right
hand left hand right hand left hand
right hand left hand boom chick boom
chick boom chick you know keeping that
one two one two thing going and likewise
when I'm moving my POI in Split time
opposites I have to do the same thing
thinking boom chick boom chick boom
chick or one two one two one two as
opposed to just one two one two as I
would be moving them in together
opposites right so kinesthetically
there's a lot of reason to feel as
though
this and this are both together time and
that this and this are both split time
right
but as frequently happens as you know I
got deeper into Theory I you know you
get to a point eventually in talking
about the mathematics of poi where the
kinesthetic simply cease to matter
um you know it becomes less a matter of
when am I putting energy in the POI and
more of like when I put together like a
matrix of all of these different things
put together
why is this split time and this is not
it seems very very arbitrary especially
if like you're using graphs or something
like that
Well turns out there is actually a good
explanation for this and it involves
thinking in atomics atomics are when you
don't have the POI in the same plane at
the same time and these are kind of
difficult to visualize like on video
like this because video tends to flatten
everything into two Dimensions it's one
of the reasons why two-dimensional style
POI spending really took off when when
video sharing platforms became a big
deal but if I'm say spending my POI like
this what's kind of interesting about it
is that from the perspective that on
that you're looking at it right now it
doesn't look that different from split
time opposites but if I show you this
from the side here it looks more like
split Time same direction and you know
kind of from my perspective what I'm
seeing is that the two planes are
basically arranged like an X yeah but
it's an X where one plane's going off
that way and one plane is going off that
way that is the both vertical but
um they are they're arranged in such a
way that I can tell that there's
something strange going on here but the
audience might not be able to right
now here's what's cool about this
um because they're arranged in an X
there's two different ways that we can
flatten them down we can either flatten
them down like this or we can flatten
them down like this right
um we it's basically like you know
having an accordion and we can both
flatten them down to a space where
they're kind of in uh wheel plane or we
can flatten them down to a space where
they're in wall plane like so different
things happen when we do each of these
namely as I am having the POI mesh here
this is in atomics this is sometimes
called a mesh
if I flatten them down to wall plane
we recognize this as split time
opposites right whereas if I flatten
them down to wheel plane if I turn to
the side here you'll see me spinning
them in Split Time same direction yeah
so
really you can think of this position
right here as essentially being the
platonic ideal of split time it is
neither split time opposites nor split
Time same direction and it's both all at
the same time it is a way to spin POI
that it can become either of these
options depending upon how you want to
flatten down those planes
and this to me mathematically makes a
lot of sense all of the sudden I
understood the relationship between
split time opposites and split Time same
direction as working outside of a place
where I had to keep counting my head it
was something that from a mathematical
perspective you know I could place this
going any direction and it would work
for me
um so if you are a nerd about the stuff
in the same way that I am I hope this is
Enough To Noodle your Noggin and draw
some connections here and if you are not
I hope you're at least patient this
patient enough to sit through to the end
and get the explanation of why these
both truly are split time patterns
because we have our split time or our
split time Atomic here and it's neither
an opposites nor same direction but from
here we can flatten down
to either option and thus they have
split time in common yay
awesome
um thanks so much for watching if you
got anything out of this video please uh
make sure to like share comment and
subscribe to help other people find it
so that they may be able to nerd out on
POI the way we just have and of course
to help my channel grow
[Music]
foreign
would not be possible were it not for
the kind sport of all of these awesome
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon and they along
with the people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
so thank you one and all for your
generous support and if you out there
watching happen to enjoy the content
that I create but are not yet a
supporter hey that's okay you can become
one very easily you can do that by
heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactor POI and signing up you can do
that at the link down in the description
or the card that just popped up if
you're watching this video on YouTube
and once you sign up you can gain access
to a variety of awesome rewards but most
importantly you will be helping to make
these videos happen you will be helping
me out in connecting with people all
across the world and helping them
discover their bodies and their brains
through the art of hoist spinning and
flow Arts so go check that out please
and thank you if you liked this lesson
and you'd like to see other lessons like
it I have a playlist full of these kind
of off the cuff real time lessons that I
will link to down in the description as
well as up here on screen if you're
watching on YouTube and also the YouTube
algorithm thanks based upon your past
viewing habits that you might like this
top video here so uh maybe give that a
look as well thank you so much for
watching make sure to get out and flow
today and I will see you with a brand
new video very soon
peace